these are the warnings listed on their  msds and yet they're still allowed to  put these products on shelves it causes  serious irritation to skin into eyes and  has long lasting toxic effects on  aquatic life reading msdss can be quite  scary i'm sure  but remember therefore ingredients when  they're pure in a cream the fragrance  will be diluted as hell  you need less than half a percent for a  big smell in beauty products you'll be  getting a tiny dose the effects i'll  have on you won't even be close  msds warnings are for industrial use and  amounts but in toxicology it's dose and  route of exposure that counts  let's look at this scary msds hold your  breath because this causes scarring of  lungs and may lead to death  avoid repeated skin contact may impair  vision  suspect a cause of cancer known human  carcinogen  now before you run off and demand this  substance be banned this msds is  actually just full  beach sand